as marijuana legalization is underway in  America there are a number of lessons  that can be learned from the end of  prohibition here are three of them as we  saw during Prohibition the demand to  drink alcohol was still there but it was  simply just driven underground what cyka  over a course was a black market fueled  by violence and bathtub gin after the  end of prohibition many states put a  great deal of regulation in place to  control alcohol even today when you  visit some micro breweries they can't  even sell you a pint of their own beer  [Music]  in many states like Pennsylvania and  Virginia consumers still have to go to  these state-run Soviet like packaged  stores that offer neither good prices  nor good selection let's hope with the  legalization of marijuana that we learn  the lessons from prohibition and not  make the same mistakes with pot that we  did with alcohol  [Music]